the Sony spider-man Cinematic Universe
continues its expansion with Morbius the
living vampire and I think we got a good
one on our hands here
nay I say we got a great one on our
hands after all this is from the
director of safe house child 44 and life
and the screenwriter of Dracula untold
the last witch hunter and gods of Egypt
starring the man who redefined the Joker
Jared Leto and the man who
single-handedly has carried the fast
franchise Tyrese Gibson a man who's
great with his money we are all in
well-trusted hands oh by the way the
Oscars came out Joker's got 11 Oscar
nominations I'm sure Jared Leto is
really happy about that
we're gonna do a live stream later today
talking about those noms probably around
3:45 Pacific Standard Time so subscribe
and click that notification bell so you
can get notified when that last room is
up or for other videos let's swing into
this
[Music]
Jerris string music answer Zimmer
I
it's being harassed yes
yes
it's a real back-end
I don't have any games what yeah bass
drought
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I got buses like riders
that's the echolocation
[Music]
spider-man tyrese and mess show us
it's the promo pick
[Music]
it's really really tidy it's crossing
over there Tom Hardy where's Tom Oh all
the Tom's well you did see spider-man in
the background and said murderer right
there
did that kind of looks like the Tobey
Maguire outfit it does look kind like to
tell me teamuk gee maybe you'll get your
spider verse with all the live action
spider-man I hope so I mean that looks
cool that is probably after far from
home and then of course Michael Keaton's
vulture showing us yeah man
it's exciting sony and marble clearly
work something really start time yeah
yeah whole title sequence from the
studio that brought you in and they're
going shouldn't this be like one of
those studios that brought you because
that's gonna obviously confuse people
for intentional reasons well it's like
when the venom promos are coming out all
the is it connected to MCU were not this
clearly connected yes I don't know what
deal they worked out but that's pretty
cool to see those spider-man tired that
sinister six universe now let's talk
about the actual trailer of Morbius
itself I didn't know much about the
movie what the approach was gonna be to
this I was assuming you know it's a
vampire story of sorts so I was like
okay it's gotta be somewhat horror based
and you got some of that like horror
grain look kind of like that conjuring
universe vibe mixed with some
cinematography that really reminded me
of the venom look an aesthetic sort of
grimy looking stuff here weirdly even
though this trailer was consistent in
the tone with the music that it had it
seemed to be a very serious movie you
know I'm still a little bit unsure what
the overall vibe would be they're
calling this a teaser trailer and even
though it's pretty long I could see why
it's a teaser cuz I'm still like what's
really the personality of this movie is
it gonna be a superhero movie because
you see Morbius doing all this like
really cool stuff that looks super
heroic I didn't know what Jared Leto was
his approach was gonna be with this I
remember Morbius from the neogenic
storyline in the spider-man 90s animated
series who had like a real Transylvanian
kind of thing
even in the comics I think it was the
reasons yeah yeah so and then here it
just seems like American and for a guy
with his handicap and his rare blood
disease he turned out great looking
lucky him I think I didn't know if
they're gonna make Michael Moore be his
pre Morbius
when he gets infected with a vampire bat
DNA if he would you know be a little bit
unattractive apparently no exactly like
Jared Leto man he'll become a very buff
Jared Leto because that's what
superpowers do no matter how you mess
them up they make you buff abs pecs all
of you buff what did you think I thought
this was a pretty cool trailer all
things considered it kind of reminded me
of Lea a Doctor Strange circa Batman
Begins circa venom yeah it looks pretty
intense and serious and stuff like that
it looks kind of maybe a bit solitary
I'm very skeptical of the Sony
spider-verse but given the parts of
venom that did work yeah and the tone
were being presented with here I'm like
cautiously optimistic about this and I'm
excited for I know people got really
jazzed when they put out the promo image
of him in the actual Morbius
transformation a great yeah that looks
practical I mean the eyes look a little
digital and they probably did digital
enhancements obviously even though they
don't get a full body image that is very
slight yeah like the scowling eyebrows
like it doesn't looks like something
that would be too hard to do with makeup
and look pretty convincing I guess what
is kind of missing for me when I was
talking about like the tones pretty
evident and how serious of a trailer it
is and again venom was pretty serious
that you're not a lot more goofy
anticipated I am wondering what this is
truly unique about this one you know
other than the fact that you ha are
having a vampire character here it seems
like Sony's spider-verse is very
antihero based right now yeah I can kind
of expect some of that vibe too well I'm
wondering if they're building up their
own sort of sinister six or insidious
six are they gonna have like venom and
Morbius go up against spider-man like
whoa and they because there are talks
about Kraven the hunter
developing that one as well I'm not sure
what to do with this factor these
franchises they do have blade coming
into the MCU late and Morbius of cross
paths yeah which just makes sense
considering who blade hunts either way I
mean the fact that they they're
connecting this more towards the MCU I
do wonder if they let Kevin Feige have
some input on this one I feel like they
they oughta if they want those
crossovers with the MCU as badly as
they've been hinting that they yeah you
know and they're like Tom Holden's gonna
make a cameo in venom too like I bet
that if that arrangement got made some
involvement from the MCU proper had to
have been struck I guess what I really
want for this is to truly commit to the
darkness that is communicating is a lot
of this honestly could be really just
corny and very cheesy it really can be
come on
like the first half of the show or if
they pull off the tone it could be very
effective I am concerned about it being
unintentionally cheesy when it's trying
to be this serious yeah especially
because you know like Jared 'la there's
something about Jared Leto and these
types of performances - we're like even
as Joker for how gleeful Joker is
there's there's like not a sense of fun
I have gotten from him in a comic-book
environment and even though I do
appreciate you know that not every comic
book movie has to be fun
I do think that yeah you need to strike
the right balance so that this isn't
just an over serious dour like wacky
finish yeah you know because I feel like
yeah it could easily Teeter on that but
if it does keep the right level of
height I think a lot of the stuff
they're showing here looks pretty cool
and Eminem is doing the song for this
one - Morbius
this looks better than I actually
thought I would look it's not gonna be
rated R I really hope that's somehow
they could double down on the violence
like really at least Teeter towards our
ratings I may be things like what maybe
they haven't yeah especially with having
the horror elements to it make it edgy
yeah really just make you feel like this
feels r-rated but it's not yeah at least
go there with your the other thing I
really thought we'd probably get like
antihero vibes this feels just like a
hero that's the thing I most got that
was a Doctor Strange feels like okay
this guy's gonna go through a procedure
things are gonna get way messed up then
he's gonna have to like torturously
learn his power
then you know figure out if any all
right guys what do you think of this
Morbius trailer you excited for it do
you have a lot of faith what comics do
you recommend do you think this will be
better than Jared Leto's Joker
performance are you sick of people
talking about Jer Leto's Joker
performance comment below before I wrap
this up I like to end this with a page
from the day shout-out to a handsome man
named JN Valenti I really went through
the list of shoutouts and I said who is
the one that has the most event Pirates
him to him and I would have to say it's
JN first off European I always imagined
a sort of a Transylvanian accent when it
comes to the guy he disappears for a
long period of time I'm assuming because
he needs to suck on some blood and
regenerate oh yeah that's just the the
vibe I get from you Jan all the
traveling you've done you you have to
have been like you know abducted and
bitten at some point maybe that's why we
don't hear from you very often maybe
it's hard to find internet during the
nighttime where you're at come visit us
in bat form cuz that would probably be
easier on you and you get a workout and
getting here that's what I have to add
to this yes you have